6 кілометрів від кордону з Білоруссю.
Приблизно 170 - від Житомира.
Доїхати до села Козулі можна ось цими пісками і лише коли сухо.
Здається, що розвиток цивілізації тут зупинився
ще у 70-их роках минулого століття.
Тут ніколи не було ані газу, ані вуличного освітлення.
Школа працювала в одному з цих дерев’яних будинків,
побудованих ще після Другої світової війни.
Єдиний магазин закрився років десять тому.
Оце така житка в нас.
Хліб нам возять через день.
Вішаємо на плоту, як їх, торби.
Скільки грошей туди положимо
виходимо, забираємо хліб.
Листоноші нам замість пошти носять
і олію, і пряники, і все возять.
Миколі Антоновичу - 84 роки.
Він називає себе найстаршим у селі, в якому живе усього 9 осіб.
Микола Антонович живе разом з дружиною.
Наразі вона не виходить з дому, зламала одразу і руку, і ногу.
Баба – 80-ть років. Бачите, як попрала з дідом.
Колись Микола Антонович працював водієм -
возив керівників навколишніх колгоспів,
де працювали майже усі жителі села.
Вже тоді тут мешкало лише з півсотні людей.
Остаточно життя у селі завмерло з розпадом СРСР,
каже Микола Антонович.
Він жаліється, що немає здоров’я ані дрова власноруч рубати,
ані машиною кудись виїхати.
Навіть бджільництвом займатися, вже сил не стало.
Сьогодні нарубав уже
Старенькі живуть з власного господарства.
Окрім пенсії, мають ще земельний пай, який здають в оренду фермерам.
Микола Антонович слідкує за подіями в країні
і навіть обізнаний про старт земельної реформи.
Продавати не будемо!
Не буде землі, то не буде і житки в Україні
Микола Антонович каже, що не усі померлі власники ось цих будинків
встигли отримати паї та передати їх родичам.
Невитребуваних паїв в таких вмираючих селах багато,
підтверджують і в місцевій Словечанській громаді.
Щонайменше третина розпайованих земель.
Усього в громаді кілька сотень людей
не витребували приблизно 1100гектарів.
Деякі мешканці померли, не встигнувши оформити документи.
Багато успадкованих паїв так і не переоформили родичі померлих.
В сільраді не виключають, що дані про кількість невитребуваних земель
можуть бути і неточними.
Тут чекають на проведення інвентаризації сільгоспземель,
яку Держгеокадастр обіцяв завершити до кінця 2019 року.
Коли вона пройде, ми знатимемо, що вже дійсно
ніхто на них не претендує.
Тоді ми даємо об’яву в республіканську газету
і починається процедура очікування - це рік.
Після року ми починаємо її оформляти,
як оформимо, ставимо її на баланс сільської ради,
що це землі вже дійсно сільської ради, ні пайовика, нікого.
Для ОТГ, у якої своїх лише 750 гектарів,
ще тисяча додатковихгектарів не завадять.
Завдяки земельній реформі їх можна буде або здавати в оренду, або навіть продати.
Щоправда, голова ОТГ великого оптимізму щодо можливих прибутків
і взагалі відкриття ринку землі, не має.
Каже, що черги з зацікавлених інвесторів,
які будуть вкладати гроші в землю поки не бачить.
А бачить те, що люди ще до відкриття ринку землі
поспіхом продають свої паї.
Продають неофіційно, нікому ж не секрет.
Хто як купить.
По українських селах їздять шахраї і видурюють у літніх людей
документи на землю, подейкують в селі Козулі.
Тож з недовірою ставляться до незваних гостей.
Це відчула на собі і знімальна група DW.
Сусід Миколи Антоновича прибіг на допомогу, запідозривши злі наміри.
Утім,  той готовий  і сам постояти за свої землі і господарство.
Собака буде гавкати, а ми з сокирою будемо бігти
і міліцію викликати.
В сусідньому селі Мацьки, теж вимираючому,
мешкає більше людей -  десь  два десятки.
За землі навколо, здається, взагалі ніхто не переймається.
Микола Старовойт каже, що шахраям
тут нічого робити.
Тут не було ніколи нічого і не буде. Бо тут пісок і ліс.
Треба тримати худобу. Худоби не буде, тут нічого не буде рости.
Ось там будете їхати та побачите,
яка в них кукурудза поросла, що посіяли. От-така!
Свій пай Микола здавати в оренду не хоче.
Каже, грошового зиску від цього - нуль.
Мовляв, ще жодному фермеру тут не вдавалося зібрати гарний урожай.
Хай в мене куплять землю. А як я отримаю 50000 євро за гектар,
то я собі куплю хорошу хату та ще і бабу в придачу!
Микола Старовойт, звісно, жартує, бо знає,
що за його пай можутьне дати й тисячієвро.
Його дружина Марія натомість, коли йдеться про землю,
жартівливого настрою чоловіка не поділяє.
Ось, все вже позаростало. Ви подивіться.
а хату зайдіть. Навколо.
Там хіба одні вовки можуть ходити.
Ліс наступає дуже швидко, каже Марія.
Років через п'ять і село може геть зарости.
Тож шансів у земельної реформи тут немає, знов жартує її чоловік.
Він припускає, що швидше усі ці сільгоспземлі стануть
частиною місцевого лісництва.
А селяни будуть заробляти не на полях, а в лісі:
гриби та ягоди збирати чи кошики з лози плести.
Скільки земель вже втрачено не лише тут, на Житомирщині,
а скрізь по Україні, ще слід підрахувати.
Натомість вже відома інша сумна статистика:
понад чотири тисячі українських сіл - на межі зникнення.